vamos a explorar otro mecanismo que
podemos tener con un acetona y de hecho
podría ocurrir el mismo tipo de reacción
con una de ido así que vamos a decir que
tengo un acetona que se ve así voy a
dibujar al grupo carbón y lo justo así y
esto está unido a un carbono que está
unido a dos grupos ch3 y solo para que
quede claro hay tres hidrógenos unidos a
este carbono de manera implícita pero yo
voy a dibujar el cuarto enlace aquí el
cual va a un hidrógeno ya que este
hidrógeno va a ser importante para esta
reacción ahora sabemos que el oxígeno
tiene dos pares de electrones libres voy
a dibujarlos aquí vamos a imaginar que
la acetona está flotando en un poco de
agua y sabemos que en el agua hay una
cierta concentración de iones hidronew y
digamos que uno de los iones hidronew
está justo aquí
el yang y drone ya está cargado
positivamente así es como se ve el agua
y si el agua regala un electrón a un
protón se ve de esta manera se vuelve un
guión idóneo y entonces solo tiene un
par de electrones libres ya que donó uno
de sus pares de electrones libres a un
protón así que podrías imaginar una
realidad en la que la acetona puede
agarrar un protón de éste hidronew y
convertir esta molécula de nuevo en agua
y en esa situación
el mecanismo se vería así déjenme
hacerlo en un color diferente este
electrón azul es donado a este protón si
chocan entre ellos de manera correcta y
luego el electrón del hidrógeno es
tomado de vuelta por lo que será
convertido en una molécula de agua así
que si eso sucede cómo se verán nuestras
moléculas ahora ahora lo que fue una
acetona se ve un poco diferente de un
acetona se ve de esta manera
he cambiado a un color amarillo por lo
que se ve así tenemos este par de
electrones libres pero ya no tenemos
este par de electrones libres de este
lado todavía tenemos este electrón en
magenta pero ahora está formando un
enlace covalente con el electrón azul
que fue donado al protón de hidrógeno
fue donado a este protón de hidrógeno de
aquí y entonces esta molécula y drone ya
se lleva un electrón y ahora es solo una
molécula de agua neutra acepto de vuelta
a ese electrón magenta por lo que ahora
tiene dos pares de electrones libres de
nuevo siendo sólo agua neutra ya que
este oxígeno de aquí en el grupo carbón
y lo donó un electrón ahora tiene una
carga positiva y esto está estabilizado
por resonancia otra forma de resonancia
para esta molécula sería si esta
molécula que es positiva quiere ganar un
electrón así que toma un electrón de
este carbono el carbono en el grupo
carbón y lo
aquí así que si se lleva a ese electrón
la otra forma de resonancia se vería así
tenemos un solo enlace con este oxígeno
de aquí este carbono de aquí abajo
todavía está unido a los mismos átomos
de carbono y luego este carbono por aquí
podríamos llamarlo carbono alfa
este es un carbono alfa al grupo carbón
y lo todavía tiene un hidrógeno justo
aquí y este oxígeno debido a que ganó
este electrón en magenta ahora tiene dos
pares de electrones libres tiene este
par de electrones ahí y luego ganó este
electrón y este electrón por lo que
tiene otro par de electrones libres y
por supuesto tiene el enlace con el
hidrógeno puesto que ganó un electrón
ahora es neutral este carbono perdió un
electrón por lo que ahora es positivo
así que ahora este carbono de aquí es
positivo
estas dos son formas de resonancia por
lo que se estabilizan la una a la otra y
en realidad la estructura de la molécula
se encuentra en algún lugar entre estas
dos formas de resonancia de hecho podría
dibujarlo entre corchetes para mostrar
que estas dos moléculas son estructuras
de resonancia y de hecho no debí de
haber dibujado esta flecha con un solo
sentido ya que esta zona podría tomar un
hidrógeno de este ión hidronew o una
molécula de agua podría tomar un
hidrógeno de esta otra molécula por lo
que esta reacción puede ocurrir en ambas
direcciones así que quiero dejar eso en
claro esto podría ir en ambas
direcciones se podría decir que están en
equilibrio entre sí tan probable es que
vaya en una dirección como en la
dirección contraria pero ahora pueden
ver que esto ha pasado de ser un grupo
carbón y lo a ser un grupo o h esto se
ha convertido ahora en un alcohol y
tenemos este carbón de aquí
al cual no le gusta ser positivo por lo
que podemos imaginar que este electrón
de aquí en este núcleo de hidrógeno
podría querer ir a este carbó catión y
que sólo necesita que alguien más se
quede con este protón para poder irse
con el carbó katiana y el candidato
perfecto para eso sería una molécula de
agua tenemos esta molécula de agua
flotando alrededor tiene dos pares de
electrones libres puede actuar como una
base débil puede donar uno de sus
electrones a este protón de hidrógeno y
si lo hace en el momento correcto y de
la manera correcta este electrón puede
entonces irse con el carb ocasión y si
eso sucede esta parte de la reacción
puede ir en ambas direcciones tan
probable es que ocurra esta reacción
como que ocurra la reacción inversa así
que dibujaré la flecha de equilibrio y
si eso llegara a suceder entonces lo que
empezó como nuestra acetona ahora se ve
así tenemos un enlace
grupo h y ahora voy a dibujar el resto
de la molécula teníamos una molécula que
se veía así pero ahora ya que este
electrón formó un enlace con éste carbó
catión ahora tenemos un doble enlace
aquí entre lo que era un carbono
carbónico y nuestro carbono alfa así que
ahora tenemos este doble enlace por aquí
este hidrógeno fue tomado por el agua y
ahora tenemos unión y drone yo voy a
dibujar el guión y drone ya así que el
agua tenía un par de electrones libres y
luego el otro par de electrones libres
se separó ya que dio uno de los
electrones a este hidrógeno de aquí y
regreso a ser unión y drone ya así que
veamos que ha pasado aquí comenzamos con
un acetona y a veces a esto le llamamos
la forma seto de la molécula y luego
terminamos con algo llamado la forma en
all la palabra en él proviene del hecho
de que es uno
y también es un alcohol incluso se le
podría llamar un al canal ya que uno de
los carbonos que forman el doble enlace
tiene unido un grupo o h y la razón por
la que te enseñe este mecanismo es solo
para mostrar un mecanismo que podría
suceder con una de ido o con un acetona
esta fue una acetona pero si este de
aquí hubiera sido un hidrógeno la
reacción habría ocurrido con una de ida
además este es un mecanismo muy común
que verás en tus clases de química
orgánica y que en realidad tiene un
montón de funciones en biología en
general y estas dos moléculas esta
acetona y esta forma en all estos son
llamados auto meros
auto - y la forma acepto es en realidad
la forma más estable en una solución que
así no se encuentra la forma en 'la
aunque sí puede ocurrir la forma aceptó
puede llegar a la forma en all a través
de este equilibrio y así te puedes
imaginar
estos son tanto menos por lo que a este
mecanismo se le conoce como una
automatización y estas son las formas
ceto y enol de los auto meros